Imagine you're in charge of government
and you decide that it's time to take your existing jungle council
and you're going to switch it over to STV.
One of the things that is an option is
because STV requires there to be more than one representative per range,
you can either triple, at a bare minimum
or quintuple the number of politicians you have,
which might be something you want to do
but there many good reasons why you might not want to do that.
Here's a more reasonable way
in which you actually switch over a country to STV.
Here is a map of our current electoral ranges
each of which sends one representative.
So, Step 1 is we're going to get rid of all these ranges
and we're going to redraw the boundaries.
So instead of everybody getting elected from one range
we're going to draw ranges that have five representatives in each.
Now, if local representation means anything
you're probably going to want to try draw these boundaries
in meaningful ways in your country.
So, they follow natural boundaries,
or they follow town boundaries, or historical boundaries..
you're going to want to try to match those as close as you reasonably can.
But an important thing to realize
is that you do not have to have all of the ranges
be the exact same size in terms of representatives.
So, in the bottom corner of the map over here
you can see we have a kind of "animal city."
And so what you can do is
instead of trying to divide that up into
a bunch of 5 representative ranges
you can take it and say "No we're just going to cut it into two."
There's the north half of the city, and the south half of the city
and that's two ranges with nine representatives each.
Now you may be asking "Why don't you just make it one range with 18 representatives?"
The answer is there's a kind of trade-off for making larger ranges
The larger the range is that you have a benefit
in that it is going to be more representative of the local population.
So, in theory, a range with 40 or 50 representatives
would be even better than a range with just, say, five.
But the price you pay for a bigger range
is a more complicated election
because if there are, say, nine seats open
you're probably going to have at least twenty candidates running
So if you actually have a range that has eighteen seats available
you're probably looking at an election that that's going to have 40 or 50 candidates
which is a little bit beyond what you can expect a reasonable person to be able to distinguish among.
Even eighteen is getting a bit up there
which is why reasonable STV systems allow you to just list your favorites
as far as you care to go. Say 1-5.
And then just not fill in the ballot anymore because you don't care anymore
Now the flipside to this problem is when you have a very sparsely populated region
as we have in the upper left here.
Many countries have their own version of fly-over regions
where the population is widely, widely distributed and very thin.
In that case, trying to draw a range that had five representatives might just be comically large,
so big as to just make a mockery of the very notion
that these representatives are "local", in any sense of that word.
So if you have a very sparsely populated region
you can have a smaller range as well.
So in this case we're going to make one range with three representatives in the corner.
Now, as before, the advantage you get with a smaller election
is that it is easier to follow - there are going to be fewer candidates running.
However, smaller ranges are much more susceptible to intentional gerrymandering
and three is at about that number.
If your country is switching over to Single Transferrable Vote
and it wants to make all of the ranges three
you should be very suspicious because three is gerrymander-able.
It is going less proportionate than a larger range.
It is acceptable under certain, reasonable circumstances
but it definitely shouldn't be the standard.
Five should really be the minimum, and nine should probably be the maximum.